it's like why does math have to exist
okay that's the best question yeah okay
fair question
um
let's see i think the thing to think
about is
the existence of mathematics is
something where
given a definition of terms
what follows from that definition
inevitably follows
so now you can say
why define any terms
but in a sense the
well that that's okay so the the
definition of terms
i mean i think the way to think about
this let me see so like
concrete terms
mistakes concrete i mean they're just
things like you know um
logical or
right that's a thing
that's a powerful thing well it's a it's
a yes okay but it's it's a
the point is that it is not a thing
about you know people imagine
there is i don't know
the uh uh you know an elephant or
something or the you know elephants are
presumably not necessary objects they
are they happen to exist as a result of
kind of biological evolution and
whatever else
but
the
the thing is that
in some sense that there is it is a
different kind of thing to say does plus
exist
the the it's not it's not not like an
elephant so a plus it seems more
fundamental more basic than an elephant
yes but
you can imagine
a world without
plus or anything like it like why do
formal things that are discreet
that can be used
to reason have to exist or uh well okay
so why okay so that then the question is
but the whole point is computation we
can certainly imagine computation that
is we can certainly say there is a
formal system that we can construct
abstractly in our minds that is
computation
and that
that's the um uh and you know we can we
can imagine it right now the question is
um is it is
that formal system
once we exist as observers embedded in
that formal system that's enough to have
something which is like our universe
yeah and so then the then what you're
kind of asking is perhaps
is
why
i mean the point is we definitely can
imagine it there's nothing that says
that we're not saying
that
there's it's sort of inevitable
that
that
is a thing that we can imagine we don't
have to ask does it exist we're just it
is definitely something we can imagine
now that's then we have this thing that
is a formally constructable thing that
we can imagine and now we have to ask
the question
what you know given that formally
constructable thing
what is uh what consequences does that
if we were to perceive that formerly if
if we were embedded in that formally
constructable thing what would be
perceived about the world and we would
say we perceive that the world exists
because we are we are seeing all of this
mechanism of all these things happening
and but that's something that is just a
feature of it's it's it's something
where we are
see another way of asking this that i'm
trying to get at
i understand why it feels like
this uh
ruliad is
necessary
but maybe it's just me being human but
it feels like
then you should be able to not us but
somehow step outside of the roulette
like what's outside the roulette
well the ruling out is all formal
systems
so there's nothing because but that's
what a human would say i know that's
what a human would say because we're
used to the idea that there are there's
but the whole point is that by the time
it's all possible formal systems
it's it's like it is all things you can
imagine
but not all computations you can imagine
but like we don't
well so what we don't that could be
other code okay so so that's a that's a
fair question is it possible to encode
uh all
i mean once we is is that something that
isn't what we can represent formally
right that is that is there's something
that um and that's i think related to
the hyper rouliad footnote so to speak
you know one of the things sort of
interesting about this is
you know there has been some discussion
of this in theology and things like that
um but uh which i don't necessarily
understand all of um but the the key
sort of new input is this idea
that all possible formal systems it's
like you know if you make a world people
say well you make a world with a
particular in a particular way with
particular rules but no you don't do
that you can make a world that deals
with all possible rules and then merely
by virtue of living in a particular
place in that world so to speak we have
the perception we have of of what the
world is like now i have to say the the
um uh it's sort of interesting because i
i've you know i wrote this piece about
this and i i
you know this philosophy stuff is not
super easy and i i've
um i as i'm as i'm talking to you about
it and i actually haven't you know
people have been interested in lots of
different things we've been doing but
this why does the universe exist has
been i would say one of the one of the
ones that you would think people will be
most interested in but actually i think
they're just like oh that's just
something complicated that that um so so
i haven't i haven't explained it as as
much as i've explained a bunch of other
things and i have to say i think i i
think i may be missing a couple of
pieces of that argument that um uh would
be so so it's kind of a like well your
your uh conscious being is
confidentially bounded so you're missing
having written quite a few
articles yourself you you're now missing
some of the pieces yes
right
one of the consequences of this why do
you know why the universe exists thing
and this kind of concept of
ruling ads and and uh you know places in
there representing our perception of the
universe and so on one of the weird
consequences is
if the universe exists mathematics must
also exist
and that's a weird thing because
mathematics people have been very
confused including me have been very
confused
about um uh the the question of kind of
what
uh what is the foundation of mathematics
what is what kind of a thing is
mathematics is mathematics
something where we just write down
axioms like euclid did for geometry and
we just build the structure and we could
have written down different axioms and
we'd have a different structure or is it
something that has a more fundamental
sort of truth to it and i have to say is
one of these cases where i've i've long
believed that mathematics has a great
deal of arbitrariness to it that there
are particular axioms that kind of got
written down by the babylonians and uh
you know that's what we've ended up with
the mathematics that we have and i have
to say actually my my wife has been
telling me for 25 years she's a
mathematician she's been telling me
you're wrong about the foundations of
mathematics and and you know i'm like no
no no i know what i'm talking about and
finally
she's she's much more right than than
i've been so it's um
so i mean
her sense
in your sense are we just uh so this is
to the question of
mathematics so we're just
kind of on the trajectory through
rule space except in mathematics through
a trajectory a certain kind of
thing that's partly the idea so so i
think that the notion is this so 100
years ago a little bit more than 100
years ago but people have been doing
mathematics for ages but then in the in
the late 1800s people decided to try and
formalize mathematics
and say you know it is mathematics is
you know we're going to break it down
we're going to make it like logic we're
going to make it out of out of sort of
fundamental primitives and that was
people like fraga and piano and hilbert
and so on and they kind of got this idea
of let's do kind of euclid but even
better let's just make everything just
in terms of this sort of symbolic axioms
and then build up mathematics from that
and that you know they thought at the
time as soon as they get
these symbolic axioms that they made the
same mistake the kind of computational
irreducibility mistake they thought as
soon as we've written down the axioms
then it'll just we'll just have a
machine
kind of a super mathematica so to speak
that can just grind out all true
theorems of mathematics
that got exploited by godel's theorem
which is basically the story of
computational irreducibility it's that
even though you know those underlying
rules you can't deduce all the
consequences in any finite way and so so
that was but now the question is okay so
they broke mathematics down into these
axioms and they say now you build up
from that
so what i'm increasingly uh coming to
realize is that's similar to saying
let's take a gas and break it down into
molecules
there's gas laws that are the
large-scale structure and so on that we
humans are familiar with and then
there's the underlying molecular
dynamics and i think that the axiomatic
level of mathematics which we can access
with automated theorem proving and proof
assistance and these kinds of things
that's the molecular dynamics of
mathematics and occasionally we see
through to that molecular dynamics
we see undecidability we see other
things like this one of things i've
always found very mysterious is that
godel's theorem shows that there are
sort of things which cannot be finitely
proved in mathematics there are proofs
of arbitrary length infinite length
proofs that you might need but in
practical mathematics mathematicians
don't typically run into this they just
happily go along doing their mathematics
and i think what's actually happening is
that what they're doing is they're
looking at
this they are essentially observers
in
meta-mathematical space
and they are picking a reference frame
in meta-mathematical space and they are
computationally bounded observers in
meta-mathematical space which is causing
them to deduce that the laws of matter
mathematics and the laws of mathematics
like the laws of fluid mechanics are
much more understandable than this
underlying molecular dynamics
and so what gets really bizarre is
thinking about kind of the analogy
between meta mathematics this idea of of
you exist in this kind of uh um
in the sort of space of possible um in
this kind of mathematical space where
the where the individual kind of uh
points in the in the mathematical space
are statements in mathematics and
they're connected by proofs where one
statement you know you take a couple of
different statements you can use those
to prove some other statement and you've
got this whole network of proofs that's
the kind of causal network of
mathematics of what can prove what and
so on and you can say at any moment in
the history of a mathematician of a
single mathematical consciousness you
are in a single kind of slice of this
kind of meta mathematical space you you
know a certain set of mathematical
statements you can then deduce with
proofs you can deduce other ones and so
on you're kind of gradually moving
through meta mathematical space
and so it's kind of the view is that the
reason that mathematicians perceive
mathematics to have the sort of
integrity and lack of kind of
undecidability and so on that they do is
because they like we as as observers of
the physical universe we have these
limitations associated with
computational boundedness single thread
of time consciousness limitations
basically that the same thing is true of
mathematicians perceiving sort of
meta-mathematical space and so what's
happening is that when you look at if
you look at one of these formalized
mathematic systems something like you
know pythagoras theorem it'll be it'll
take oh i don't know
uh what is it maybe 10 000 individual
little steps to prove pythagoras theorem
and one of the bizarre things that's a
sort of an empirical fact that i'm
trying to understand a little bit better
if you look at different proof of system
if you look at different formalized
mathematic systems they actually have
different axioms underneath but they can
all prove pythagoras theorem and so in
other words it's a little bit like what
happens with gases we can have air
molecules we can have water molecules
but they still have fluid dynamics both
of them have fluid dynamics and so
similarly at the level that mathematics
that mathematicians care about
mathematics it's way above the macular
dynamics so to speak
and there are all kinds of weird things
like for example one thing i was
realizing recently is that the quantum
theory of mathematics that's a very
bizarre idea but
basically when you prove
what is you know a proof
is you've got one statement in
mathematics you go through other
statements you eventually get to a
statement you're trying to prove for
example that's a path path in
meta-mathematical space
and that's a single path a single proof
is a single path
but you can imagine there are other
proofs of the same results there are a
bundle of proofs there's this whole set
of possible proofs you could think of as
branching similar to the quantum
mechanics model that you were talking
about exactly and so and then there's
some invariants that you can formalize
in the same way that you can for the
quantum mechanical right so the question
is in in proof space you know as you
start thinking about multiple proofs are
there analogs of for example destructive
interference of multiple proofs so
here's a bizarre idea it's just a couple
of days old so not not yet fully formed
but um as you try and do that when you
have two different proofs it's like two
photons going in different directions
you have two proofs which at an
intermediate stage are incompatible and
that's kind of like destructive
interference is it possible
for this to instruct the engineering of
automated proof systems
absolutely i mean as a practical matter
i mean the you know this whole question
in fact jonathan gorad has a nice
heuristic for automated theorem provers
that's based on our physics project that
is looking for essentially using
kind of uh using energy and in our
models energy is kind of level of
activity in this hyper graph
and so there's sort of a heuristic for
automated theorem proving about how do
you pick which path to go down that uh
is based on essentially physics um and i
mean the thing that that gets
interesting about this is is the way
that one can sort of have the interplay
between like for example a black hole
what is a black hole in metal
mathematics
so the answer is what is black hole in
physics so black hole in physics is
where
in the simplest form of black hole time
ends
that is all you know everything is is
crunched down to the space-time
singularity and everything just ends up
at that singularity so in our models and
that's a little hard to understand in
general relativity with continuous
mathematics and what does singularity
look like in our models it's something
very pragmatic it's just you're applying
these rules time is moving forward and
then there comes a moment where the
rules no rules apply so time stops it's
kind of like the universe dies the you
know the nothing happens in the universe
anymore well in mathematics that's a
decidable theory that's a theory so
theories which have undecidability which
are things like arithmetic set theory
all the serious models theories in
mathematics they all have the feature
that there are proofs of arbitrarily
long length
in something like boolean algebra which
is a decidable theory there are you know
any question in boolean algebra you can
just go crunch crunch crunch and in a
known number of steps you can answer it
you know satisfiability you know might
be hard but it's still a bounded number
of steps to answer any satisfiability
problem and so that's the the notion of
a black hole in physics where time stops
that's the that's analogous to in
mathematics where there aren't infinite
length proofs where when in physics
you know you can wander around the
universe forever if you don't run into a
black hole if you run into a black hole
and time stops you're done and it's the
same thing in mathematics between
decidable decidable theories and
undecidable theories that's a that's an
example and i think we're sort of the
the the attempt to understand so so
another question is kind of what is the
what is the general relativity of uh of
metamathematics what is the bulk theory
of metamathematics
so in the literature of mathematics
there are about three million theorems
that people have have published and
those represent it's kind of on this
it's like like on the earth
we would be you know uh you know we've
put cities in particular places on the
earth but yet there is ultimately you
know we know the earth is roughly
spherical and there's an underlying
space and we could just talk about you
know the world of space in terms of
where our cities happen to be but
there's actually an underlying space and
so the question is what's that for meta
mathematics and as we kind of explore
what is for example for mathematics
which is always likes taking sort of
abstract limits so an obvious abstract
limit for mathematics to take is the
limit of the future of mathematics
that is what will be you know the
ultimate structure of mathematics yeah
and one of the things that's an
empirical observation about mathematics
that's quite interesting is that a lot
of theories in one area of mathematics
algebraic geometry or something might
have they play into another area of
mathematics that that same the same kind
of a fundamental construct seemed to
occur in very different areas of
mathematics and that structurally
captured a bit with category theory and
things like that but i think that
there's probably an understanding of
this meta-mathematical space that will
explain why different areas of
mathematics ultimately sort of map into
the same thing and i mean you know my
little challenge to myself is what's
time dilation in um in metamathematics
in other words as you as you basically
as you move around in this mathematical
space of possible statements um you know
what's how does that moving around it's
basically what's happening is that as
you move around in the space of
mathematical statements it's like you're
changing from algebra to geometry to
whatever else
and you're trying to prove the same
theorem but as you try if you keep on
moving to these different places it's
slower to prove that theorem because you
keep on having to translate what you're
doing yeah back to where you started
from and that's kind of the beginnings
of the analog of time dilation amount of
mathematics plus there's probably
fractional dimensions in this space as
well
oh this space is a very messy space this
space is much messier than physical
space i mean even in even in the models
of physics physical space is is very
tame compared to branchial space and
real space um i mean the mathematical
structure you know branch shield space
probably more like hilbert space but
it's a rather complicated hilbert space
and rulial space
is more like this weird infinity
groupoid story of growth and deacon and
you know i can explain that a little bit
because in you know in in
meta-mathematical space
a a path in mathematical space is a is a
a path between two statements is a way
to get by proofs
is to way to find a proof that goes from
one statement to another
and so one of the things you can do you
can think about is you've got between
statements you've got proofs and they
are paths between statements okay so now
you can go to the next level and you can
ask what about a mapping from one proof
to another
and so that's in in category theory
that's kind of a higher category the
notion of higher categories where you're
where you're mapping not just between
not just between objects but you're
mapping between the mappings between
objects and so on and so you can keep
doing that you can keep saying higher
order proofs i want mappings between
proofs between proofs and so on and that
limiting structure oh by the way one
thing that's very interesting is imagine
in proof space you've got these two
proofs
and the question is what is the topology
of proof space in other words if you
take these two parts can you
continuously deform them into each other
or is there some big hole in the middle
that prevents you from continuously
deforming them one into the other it's
kind of like you know when you when you
think about some i don't know some
puzzle for example you're moving pieces
around on some puzzle and you can think
about the space of possible states of
the puzzle and you can make this graph
that shows from one state to the puzzle
to another state of the puzzle and so on
and sometimes you can easily get from
one state to any other state but
sometimes there'll be a hole in that
space and they'll be you know you always
have to go around the circuitous route
to get from here to there there won't be
any direct way that's kind of a question
of of whether there's sort of an
obstruction in the space and so the
question is in proof space
what is the
what are you know what does it mean if
there's an obstruction in proof space
yeah i don't even know what an uh
obstruction means in proof space because
for it to be an obstruction it should be
reachable some other way from some other
place
right so this is like an unreachable
part of the graph
no it's not just an unreachable part
it's a part where there are paths that
go one way there are parts that go the
other way and this question of homotopy
and mathematics is this question can you
continuously deform you know from one
path to another path or do you have to
go in a jump so to speak so okay so like
if you're going around a sphere for
example if you're going around
i don't know
a cylinder or something you can wind
around one way and you can there's no
paths where you can where you can easily
deform one path into another because
it's just sort of sitting on the same
side of the cylinder but when you've got
something that winds all the way around
a cylinder you can't continuously deform
that down to a point because it's it's
stuck wrapped around my intuition about
proof space is you should be able to
deform it i mean that because then
otherwise it doesn't even make sense
because
if the topology matters of the way you
move about the space that i don't even
know what that means well what it would
mean is that you would have one way of
doing a proof of something over here in
algebra yeah and another way of doing a
proof of something over here in geometry
and there would not be an intermediate
way to map between those proofs how
would that be possible if they start at
the same place and end the same place
well it's the same thing as as you know
we've got points on a you know if we've
got paths on a cylinder now i understand
how it works in physical space but it
just doesn't it feels like proof space
shouldn't have that
i okay i mean i'm not sure i don't know
we will know very soon because we get to
do some experiments this is the great
thing about this stuff is that in fact
you know i i'm in the next few days i
hope to do a bunch of experiments on
this so you're playing like proofs in in
this kind of space yes
you